all right the nfc game
um
the last time the packers and the
buccaneers bay of pigs got together it
was a a pig type day for the packers up
10 nothing then the wheels came off they
lost 38 to 10. here's packers coach matt
leflore on the last time his team saw
the buccaneers
well anytime you get beat 3810 it's hard
to say it's not as bad as it looked
um you know they they did a good job you
got to give them credit uh they came
they were they were more prepared to
play than than we than our group was so
um but i think you you always got to
take everything you can out of every
situation you're always learning i think
our team has come a long way from that
from from that day but
you know
everything's just words at this point
yeah look we saw this weekend what
happens when a team gets swept during
the regular season and statistically it
is more difficult for the team that lost
the first two
to win the third one but the buccaneers
pulled it off and that's that's all the
proof the packers need to say that 38 to
10 was an aberration we start over 0-0
we're at home it's cold it's snowy we
have the advantage and we can we can win
this game right even though the
buccaneers won the last when that one
doesn't matter now so i
i
i see no relevance at all
from the last game to this game chris
none whatsoever i'm i'm i mean
i'm with you i don't think it's it's too
relevant at least i don't look at it and
i'm i'm gonna watch back that game from
week six here after the show at some
point but i don't expect to look at it
and go
oh man this is you know this is
definitive this is the way these teams
are there's been so much change with
both of these football teams you know i
think that's really the thing worth
noting and then even in that game 38 to
10 okay yeah great
but
i i think you know
that game was very close to teetering
the other way at one point yeah ten
nothing to pick six okay now it's ten
seven he throws another interception
that gets rid of the slant route to
devonta adams on the right that goes
through his hands gets intercepted gets
returned down to the two or three yard
line the next drive he misses
you know two wide open throws one was
mercedes lewis going down the right seam
i mean uncovered gonna change the
momentum of the football game at least
back into green bay's favor to get them
going they missed that opportunity but
this is a different green bay football
team but it's a different tampa team too
both of these teams have found their
stride here as of late i think that's
what's great you know about this matchup
it's really both teams kind of peaking
at the right time
and
i don't know who's gonna win this
football game but i don't think week six
is yes a huge factor in this it's about
who's gonna execute and play the best
and the most physical and that's the
part i look at mike the physicality of
this game
i mean the bucks
pushed around the saints d-line
that that does not have they wore them
down as the game went on we've asked
those questions about the the packers
all year long they've kind of answered
the bell with that kind of stuff so i'm
really pumped to see that go down on
sunday
let me flip it over to the other side
david bacteria he's been gone for the
packers they seemingly haven't missed a
beat
right maybe back for the buccaneers as
soon as this weekend activated from into
reserve nobody thought he was going to
play again this year that beefs up the
defense and how about this stat that
matt casey dug up aaron rodgers was
blitzed 185 times this year and he was
only sacked on those 185 blitzes four
times
but three of them happened in the bucks
game so the blitz was working that day
they got to aaron rodgers repeatedly i
don't know what happened and again this
just to me
we see
rarely but we've we've witnessed it
multiple times over the last two years
the packers take the show on the road
and something goes haywire for them
right whether it's the chargers last
year the 49ers twice last year the
packers at the bucks this year there's
just something and they can never really
pinpoint it uh that's not a factor this
time they're not going anywhere they're
at home and they have fans there and
those fans made a huge difference i
remember earlier this year the packers
were having a hard time getting it going
at home in an empty lambeau field
they're there now so those factors
staying at home and having fans present
and the weather
those i'm starting to talk myself out of
thinking the bucks are going to win the
game frankly i think maybe the the
packers
are are going to be far better equipped
to avoid the 38 to 10 outcome than than
i think many people realize i i would i
mean i would be shocked if we had that
sort of game and either or a loss at all
a loss at all 38 to 10 30 to 35 13 to 10
whatever the final score i think the
packers are going to be in much better
shape to win this game than they were
the last time they played no i mean the
home field advantage you know the cold
weather all of that that all favors
green bay no doubt i mean there are a
different team like you said i think you
know you talked about the blitz and how
he's been sacked five times all year
three of them or that game hey that's an
advantage green bay too okay that's what
they did they did something a little
creative on us we know what to expect
from them now you know from that aspect
all together they'll be ready for the
buck's plan of attack as far as how
they're gonna
play them this time and i think the
biggest thing too
is the packers offensive line is so much
better now than it was then even in that
game yeah the blitz got there a few
times but they blitzed a few times just
to create one-on-ones and then guys just
got beat on one-on-one pass protection
they're they're more of a force as we
talked about over the last four or five
weeks in the run game
i don't think the bucks will just be
able to play past defense all game you
know the first time around i think they
aired on that this time you got to be
careful it's become green bay oh you got
extra guys in the box we don't care
we're still going to run it and get five
or six yards that's what's different
about the football game all together and
that's what i'm excited to see you know
both offenses i think are functioning at
a much higher level i think the packers
defense is functioning at a much higher
level the bucks defense is all over the
place last week it was awesome there's
other weeks like the week before in the
wild card game against washington where
i go well damn they look average if you
can't get to the quarterback they can't
cover anybody so that's where it's going
to be a fun one
whatever switch was flipped in the
second half of the game against the
saints on sunday they need to be able to
mash that thing and if they can do that
they'll be fine that's what's so
compelling to me about the buccaneers we
can talk about tom brady and all the
weapons but that defense is going to be
the difference one way or the other good
or bad win or lose it's going to come
down to that defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports